The Joe Rogan Experience you're dealing
with someone a company like say
Instagram how many people do they let's
guess how many people are on Instagram
what do you think well there's 350
million people in the country right but
in the world there's ah yeah Instagram
yeah billions how many people do you
think two billion what do you think I
three billion I'll say two let's see
what do you think how many people you
think are honest it's probably about one
one billion but daily active Fusion
would be less too let's let's find out
how many accounts are on Instagram let's
Google that how many individual accounts
are on Instagram I'm saying two billion
what do you think Jeremy you say one you
say like two three yeah three books the
most and it's not that it's not over 2
billion yet oh it isn't pretty sure I
thought it was Facebook's my worldwide
yeah Facebook changes elections in
places like that's crazy right I had
Zuckerberg on and you could you could
tell like having a conversation with
that guy like dang I'm off what
Instagram is 2.35 billion active users
wow that's you wow that's crazy that's a
lot yeah I guess it would be hard for
them to field I guess it would be hard
for them to feel feel like complaints or
look meanwhile that's fourth amongst the
biggest social media networks globally
so what's number one Facebook's number
one 2.9 Billion YouTube is 2.2 I don't
really consider YouTube social media not
that much right because maybe it is I
guess it is but I don't use it that way
I use it for entertainment yeah if I'm
watching YouTube I'm watching stuff like
fights or Clips yeah
WhatsApp is 2 billion well WhatsApp is a
communication app I don't think that's
social media no Instagram 2.35 tick tock
tick tock's only one billion that's
interesting I would have thought it was
way more I think it is I think it's on
the rise though isn't Tick Tock like a
thing and then um Instagram reels is
competing with it right where's Twitter
where's Twitter yes I feel like that's
I've all Twitter has never in the been
in the top ten really but it's not even
in the top oh it's way down there 397
million wow wow I think there's ones
that are [__] way more like Pinterest
Pinterest is 475 million Reddit look at
Reddit 430 million I'm not on Reddit at
all chaos Jesus yeah yeah I know guys
will go on Reddit and they read about
themselves and they go down a dark room
they get their feelings hurt bad oh
there's a bunch of intelligent vipers
runs the top five three of the top five
which is a little strange because
they've split them all up and this could
just be one app well you know messenger
could just be Facebook wasn't that one
of the things that they asked chat GPT
like do you think that Facebook is a
monopoly and should it be broken I mean
absolutely they said yes yeah what did
Zuckerberg say well I didn't ask him
about that no but for him it was
interesting because he's a very nice guy
yeah and you know people think of him as
like a robot and a thing I think he's
not that at all he's a guy who created
this thing a long ass time ago with no
anticipation of what it was going to
become and then it became this [__]
worldwide monster right this thing
that's just it's so big and yeah and you
know it's pretty interesting guy Ai and
very fourth chemical he was explained
like about how the FBI contacted him
about the hunter Biden laptop yeah and
explained it explained it on the podcast
that it created a firestorm I'm sure he
was just kind of casually explaining
well the FBI told us that there was
going to be some disinformation coming
out of Russia and you know we were told
that this and that and so we limited its
uh reach and and then just was [__]
Giant news like that this is I mean this
guy just created a [__] dating site
for college kids right you know x amount
of years ago but he was instrumental in
growing it though too you know what I
mean and with that comes like bad stuff
obviously you know not just the good the
good parts of it and also I mean more
most recently take a he took a big
blunder with that whole meta thing where
they thought that everybody was going to
put on headsets and and delve into them
oh yeah and that [__] didn't work at all
no why
it's too weird yeah I love it I mean
that's yeah that's close to I mean
that's that will mess I mean you want to
talk about social media [__] with
your mind like that meta stuff like in a
in a alternate reality well just living
you're basically getting closer to just
being in a pod you know what I mean and
having that on yes you know as your
reality it's going to happen yeah it's
going to happen it's just like look when
I was a kid in the 1980s and 90s there
was good times good times but there was
times back then where people thought
virtual reality was going to be the
future but the technology wasn't
available it didn't really work it was
but it was always this thought you know
that one day we're going to live in
virtual reality and that was The Matrix
that was like all these different things
but it was like science fictiony enough
that it was so far ahead yeah and then
the technology was kind of clunky so it
never really took off but then when
Oculus came around and what were the
other ones those there was another big
one other than Oculus Vive that's right
the HTC Vive that they were they were so
good you're like oh maybe we're close
and there's there's some fun [__]
games you can play on that apparently
there's an alien like alien one the
movie game that is [__] terrifying
and you play it and you're on the
Nostromo that that spaceship yeah and
the [__] aliens in the spaceship
right and you know you're going down
dark corridors and rains dripping and
you know another thing just jumps out at
you it's [__] terrifying apparently
but that for whatever reason they
thought that was just gonna just sweep
the whole country and everyone it was a
virtual reality mask that you put on
yeah the Oculus it's very light the new
one is very light like the old ones we
have the HTC Vive at the studio and it
had to be attached to a backpack and it
was like a cable that came above you and
we had the cable suspended from the
ceiling so we had like a sectioned off
area where you could play in it and then
uh it got better and Carmack John
Carmack got involved and you know they
made even better versions of it and then
it became something you just sit on your
head and then when that happened I was
like oh boy we're getting close now
because now it just sits in your head
and you have these two controllers in
your hand but it's still just people are
not that interested in it which is
interesting that's good I think I think
it's a good thing not to be on it I
think it's going to be the future okay
there's going to it's going to be
something that's so wonderful and so
exciting that you can't get out of it
it's going to be weird how it morphs
with your mind it's going to eventually
morph with your mind right so it'll be
like part of you kind of that's where we
kind of morph into the robot world I
guess that's happening it's gonna happen
it's just a matter of like what is it 10
years is it 20 years yeah whatever it is
but technology is going to reach a point
where it's so look no one ever would
have thought that you would have a thing
in your pocket where you couldn't stop
looking at it right it's I'm still
I'm still amazed by like I'm in New York
you know and I'm watching people and I'm
watching people just walk down the
street yeah with it on and they're not
conscious of anything else that is going
on and they're just walking down this
truth it's dangerous as cars that could
hit you it's like they're just walking
down the street just immersed in it
actually if you're on the subway and
you're not on it if you're just staring
forward like you're the weird one you're
the weird one yeah everybody else like
what's this guy doing did you get on a
subway with a book like what do you do
who the [__] is this guy throwback
you're reading a book yeah a real book
yeah it's not even a Kindle yeah it's
unreal
it's unreal yeah it's uh I had a books
on my phone now so I'm reading it on my
phone it's that's amazing to me I think
yeah I have all that that information
just a library oh yeah the library app
you can just download books from the
library on your phone and read them and
return them that's fantastic well I have
uh most of the books that I consume I
consume audiobooks I could on the way to
work coming home from work in the sauna
that's where I do most of my listening
to books and I probably have 200 300
books on this little tiny phone it's
unreal and they're all hours long yeah
like it's a terabyte of data on that
phone so there's so much room and also
it just stores in the cloud anyway so
there's no room it's in the cloud that
you can download it and it's [__]
there's never been a time that you could
have more access to information but
there's also never been a time where
you're more distracted yeah that's
that's the rub yeah that's the rub but
if you're focused on the information man
it's like it's College it's basically a
college in your pocket yeah it's
unbelievable and and
uh people listening might be like what
do you know because people grew up with
this but we didn't right like I knew a
time where this didn't exist at all like
me and my brother had a room together it
was both of us no TV allowed in the room
dinner together at a certain time unless
you're working or you or you're at a
sports practice you're having dinner my
father's playing music while we have
dinner we're talking about our day and
when we go to sleep it's like a room no
television because they he didn't want
us in our room watching television on
our own you want to watch television
you're out with the family right you
know it's it's that kind of thing so I
guess
you know it's a different world yes and
it's been a gradual thing but it's still
very very different like I don't have
kids so I don't know how that would be
but I guess I mean like what you do what
you implement with your children it
sounds like the right thing they get mad
at you yeah put your phone up yeah they
get mad because that little dopamine
rushes it's not even a big rush right
that's what's weird it's like this
little drip of dopamine yeah
but you like there's this pole like what
has anybody texting yeah
I see some people on the podcast they
can't help but they reach for their
phone yeah that's the thing like they
just they just check their text messages
and this is your podcast and it's giant
there's millions of people watching
someone just look at their phone it's
like it's not but they can't help it
they just get so sucked in I've done it
to uh to the point where it's like when
I first get up I don't I make sure I
don't look at it and uh do other things
first and then I set time aside and I
mentally prepare myself I go okay now
I'm gonna look at it I'm gonna look at
it I'm gonna do as much as I want for 15
minutes check everything make sure
everything's up check the com check the
comments and now that the special is out
like respond to people as much as I can
and then
after that window is over not again yeah
now the trick is uh YouTube because I
like to watch stuff on YouTube but it's
like I don't want to get addicted to
scrolling on YouTube either so that's
that's the difference there but I'm
definitely addicted to watching stuff on
YouTube yeah yeah when I have breakfast
I [__] I get this little it's pretty
cool this little kickstand thing that
sticks up with your phone so that's
great I think this is called a coup case
or something like that I forget what
it's called but it's like bam so I just
sit there it's great and then we'll
watch stuff for a meeting right you know
and I think I'm not addicted that way oh
I'm just being entertaining but that's
YouTube you're watching you're watching
substance there instead of mindlessly
scrolling which is what I was doing and
it just that creates so many bad like
emotions and stuff it's like I don't
want I don't want to feel that way isn't
that weird that mindlessly scrolling
creates bad emotions like what is that
why does it do that
is it just you feel like you're wasting
time you're wasting time you're seeing a
bunch of different things like uh you
know the energy coming from the thing
I'm a big energy guy too it's like the
energy coming from it is it hits
even when you're looking at your I try
that for a while looking at my own so
I'll just look at my own stuff I won't
look at everybody's stuff but then you
start getting like how many likes does
this have how many it's like you end up
yeah you end up swimming in your own
narcissism so it's like no stop that now
yes absolutely but if I'm my point is
I'm navigating this at 50 well my mind
has already been developed what chance
do kids have developing through this
time period it's a different world but I
think they're going to be fine I really
do I think there's going to be a
transitionary period where we lose a lot
of kids they don't they don't know what
the [__] they're doing and they get lost
in it
but there's going to be enough kids that
recognize like okay this is just the new
reality of life and if you want to be
successful just like you when you were
young when you had focus and dedication
you realize there's a lot of people out
there don't do that and you know I can
learn from them what not to do right
there's kids that are doing that now too
and like I have friends that very much
limit their kids access to social media
they don't allow them on things they
don't allow them to have a phone I don't
think that's the way to do it because
this is a reality and I think that if
you give the kids the tools and the
understanding to handle that it this is
a new level of adversity that they have
to deal with that we didn't have to deal
with right but it's the way I look at it
it's like cold weather like if you grew
up in a place with cold weather you
developed an understanding of what the
[__] that means like you gotta shovel
snow you got to deal with it and you div
I think they have a new level of
adversity right because of the pressures
of social media and because of like the
[__] talking the right especially with
girls Right girls are [__] mean each
other yeah because their reputation
destruction yes in the comments and [__]
on each other and group chats and it's a
it gets real nasty and you developed a
level of resilience from being able to
handle that right and after a while you
get okay with it and you have to
understand what that is but no you have
to understand what that is yeah and it's
you're right you're like going in with
that mindset is the important thing it
is if you're just caught off guard with
it yeah then it can Crush you and it has
it's driven people to Suicide it
definitely has done that and there's
also a thing the fomo aspect and the um
the comparison and this is apparently
very bad with girls as well because
there's a lot of people that are using
filters and they're changing their body
right and these girls see these people
and they look perfect and then they see
themselves in the mirror and they have
zits yeah like [__] [__] they're a
little overweight and they get massively
depressed right and then they think well
the only way for me I have to be like
that person right so I have to do what
they're doing and and be completely
focused on my looks and and some people
just unfortunately through a genetic
role of the dice they don't have good
features they don't they don't look good
they don't have a good body right and
then they just feel [__] depressed
yeah they're comparing themselves